Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to "I Am Dead, Where Are My Keys?"
Hi, Chica! You gotta go lay down! You gotta go lay down, pretty girl.
Go on! Go lay down.
She likes to steal my socks when she thinks I'm not looking,
but I know. This game is a... I don't know
Whoa, what a spooky night out tonight.
I know right!? Halloween never used to be this spoopy.
hi
HahaHi
oh shit!
what up!
how you doin
Don't you agree, Skeletony?
Skeletonie? Skeletony.
Yes wow, I do agree. It is very scary out, Skelly T.
ooohhh
I sure Hoohh shit
HI!
What the Fuck!
Is that a giant cat skeleton that just knocked out the buildings in the entire neighborhood?
Boy! This Halloween sure is the spoopyist that I've ever seen.
I FOUND YOU TWO!
WOOOHEEEHEAH!
ITS AN EMERGENCY!
OH! Youre here to help us I guess.
OH, hey Big Skull.
Yeah this is a perfectly normal occurrence in this weird skeleton neighborhood.
Halloween's in danger again!
Will you helps me save it?
Yeah, alright.
OK. Come with me.
We must unite The Candy once more.
Roger that Big Skull. We owe you one anyways.
OOOHH God!
OHH HOOH Shit!
OHH HI!
Hello Everybody!
I'm actually waving that arm.
Hey! I don't know what benefit this is gonna be for me in this adventure...
But here we go, I guess...
WEEEEEEEEEE.
Oh my god (x3)
Get the candy. Get the candy.
Hello! Hi!
I'll take some of that! Can I get some of that delicious candy?
I don't know how to... HOLY SHIT.
I'm stuck on a god damn..
Oh my God... Oh my God...
When I find... Ow.
Apparently. When I find, like, indie games, and when I say indie games I mean INDIE GAMES.
When I find indie games, sometimes it's always...
It's a- it's always a-
GET OFF THE FUCKING HUMP!
Grab the candy! God damn it!
Just grab the god damn candy!
"There are six more candy to find." OOOH GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS.
It's like the Triforce. Gotta reach into the house and get it.
(house making moaning sounds)
Woah!
Somehow I think that house got turned on by me grabbing it. Which is very bizarre...
(house still making moaning sounds)
Can I have the god damn candy? Oh, it's like embedded in the house and I got to somehow reach underneath the house's weird skirt.
Eh. Just gimme- THANK YOU.
I got it. Okay.
Wooooooooah.
OOOOOOOH.
Woah.
Okay. Alright. I'm just gonna "skeleton-ize" my way around...
Oh, I can't touch that with my bony hand.
Well,  don't know if I want to play this game!
I don't know if I want to experience the rest of what this game has to offer!
Am I driving through space?
I just realized that I'm not actually driving on the ground, I'm like-
I'm, like, LEGITIMITLLY.
"Thank you, my buds. There are four more ca-" I AM DRIVING THROUGH SPACE.
when dID tHAT hAPPEN?
I!
Okay, I'm no fool.
I'm pretty 100% sure that I was driving on the ground...
And that gravity was- was- was my master and I HAD TO OBEY
(pukes in mouth)
Oh God, I did it again.
To the left! To the right!
Oh my God...
meh meh meh meh meh.
Grab it and...
And boink! Got it. Okay...
Two left to go! I see one more!
Wooooh... OOOOOH. OOOOOOAAOOH.
aBOINK!aBOINK!aBOINK!aBOINK! There we go.
Finally! Just one more candy.
Well, I wonder where that would g- Oh! I see it!
Hello, big skull! How you doing, big champ? How you doing, big squeeze? How you doing, my main man? How you doing my, skele-buddy?
I'm legitimately terrified for my entire life. My entire existence.
Got it! Woah, where did I go? HELLO! "Yes! Thank you!"
Okay, for what? I don't know what I did, I don't know why I'm doing it...
"All seven candies are gathered in one place, we can save Halloween."
Okay, how? I'm not a hundred percent sure!
"By the power of Trick-or-Treat..." Okay.
"I wish for Halloween to be saved."
Oh, we're making a wish now. I didn't realize...
OH, WE DID IT! RAAAAAAAH! GO US!
"I'm glad we saved Halloween, it's my favorite- BLEEEEH."
"I don't think anyone even knew it was in danger."
"Skelly T. went on to become a successful divorce attorney."
AAH! AAAAAAAAAAH! WHAT HAPPENED?!
WHY HAS MY LIFE CHANGED?!
WHAT THE HELL JUST HAPPENED?!
AAAAAH!
*throws up*
"Remember to floss regularly." That is the most important thing!
"Bone nut."
(Mark trying to understand all the life-changing things that were just thrown at him)
You know those games that you play, and it's like a monumental moment in your life that changes everything you think about the universe and what you're in?
And what you do?
I think this is one of those moments!
I think honestly... I'm going to look at life differently now that I know that I helped save Halloween with Skelly T. and Big Skull
and Skeletony.
So, anyway, hopefully your life was just as changed and moved... and oh my God, I'm so sorry.
If that destroyed your entire reality like it did my own...
But thank you everybody so much for watching! You can play this game for yourself if you really want to through the link in the description below!
Thanks again for watching. And as always, I will see you in the next video! Bye-bye!